not having worked with that character in
civil war I mean that gave as
storytellers we were even more excited
to work with him in this film so Thor
has a very very special arc in this
movie that we were really excited about
his storytellers that filmmakers and no
it doesn't really come up that much
sunset I mean we have a very it's very
professional we're very dedicated to
work and I think that I think that Chris
is very happy with what's happening now
a lot of times when we're doing work in
the on the script and in a room we lock
ourselves away with the writers usually
for about six to eight months before we
start shooting we go through every scene
line by line and we make sure we
understand what we're all thinking
collectively as a group of collaborators
how what what is happening in the scene
who wants what how we're gonna execute
it visually so we really come to set
very prepared I will say it's always fun
when when you get an actor who hasn't
done a lot of this kind of work before
because it's a very different experience
you know they have to use their
imagination more in terms of what's
around them and what's happening and
talking to them through that process I
remember in civil war it was around
Winter Soldier rather was Robert Redford
you know sort of like the Virgin to this
process and on this movie Josh Brolin
has really sort of taken to it this is a
brand new experience for him and I think
he's having a lot of fun with with the
whole what what that gives him as a
performer the visual effects dimension
okay yeah we have some great female
characters in this Captain Marvel is in
it
Black Widow Scarlet Witch
we have Wakanda is coming in and there's
a whole group of characters that are
coming from the wakandan universe from
Black Panther Universe yes I mean an
amazingly strong character strong willed
characters and you know we have the
guardians and two of the guardians are
our daughters of Thanos so there's a
really strong connection to the main
villain of the story and you know I
think you'll you'll see in the film that
that they're very pivotal to the
storyline and and I think I think the
arcs are fantastic so we're really
really proud of of being able to
introduce Captain Marvel
yeah and that's the culmination of what
what these have been for years right the
long-term vision that's right yes it's
really exciting it really is I mean we
say that you know if you think of the
last 10 years of Marvel movies like a
book this is the end of the book that
we're filming right now so we're and
we're excited to bring that audiences
it's a great journey to go on together I
mean that's very rare I don't think
anything really has been done like this
in the in films before where you're
taking all these different characters
from different franchises and putting
them all together in a single film and I
think and I think they feel the the
weight of that and how special it is and
that it's it's a once-in-a-lifetime kind
of event for us as directors and for
them as actors and you seem so calm
about doing that yeah you have to stay
calm because you know if you let the
stress get to everybody it's Charlie
I've gotten all kinds of requests to do
a video for this Captain Marvel
interview where they seemingly confirmed
that she's going to be an infinity war
so I'll try to explain what that means
because just a little while ago the same
directors were saying that she was not
in the movie they also talked a little
bit about Thor he actually has the most
screen time in the movie after Thanos
technically Thanos has the most screen
time so I'll explain all that I just
wanted to include the biggest stuff from
this I had to cut it way down but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos this is just the beginning and
there is a new route of that Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway all you have
to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video but the big stuff first talking
about Captain Marvel so he says and he's
looking at his brother when he says that
I love the look that he gives them like
he pauses like he's trying to get some
sort of acknowledgment like are we
spoiling this are we giving stuff away
the interviewer had asked him about the
strong female presence in the film so he
was using her as an example of like
literal strong because she's super
powerful but also strong and that there
were a lot of good female characters
whereas it used to just pretty much be
Black Widow like she was actually joking
about that during her interview like I
was the only one for a little while kind
of like a Princess Leia situation in the
original Star Wars movies like the only
woman in the galaxy but the interview
where he said that she was not in the
movie is actually more recent I think
all these interviews that they've been
dropping recently like the footage of
the directors talking here was actually
shot last year when they were still
shooting the
part of the movie they finished that a
while ago most of the stuff they're
doing now are like reshoots or pickups
like the little extra work most of
principal photography has been done for
a while what I think their statements
mean when you kind of take it all in
context together is that she's more of a
post-credits scene so this she's not
like a big presence in the film but she
will be on screen you go to the theater
you will see a version of Captain Marvel
either in the very last post-credit
scene we don't know how many
post-credits scenes there are there
could be like three or four it could be
like guardians of the galaxy to where
they had a whole bunch of them but she's
not around for any of the main action of
the film so like you get all the way to
the end here where it looks like Captain
America's met his number she's not gonna
swoop in and save everybody because they
know still has to assemble the gauntlet
she probably only shows up right as
things get to their darkest like
remember Gandalf during two towers like
he sort of swoops in just as they're
getting ready to get their asses handed
to them it's probably a situation like
that when you get to the second film but
it is so funny to watch him and talk
about that like you rewind and you watch
that part of the video you can see him
sort of turn his head like he's not
quite sure about what he's talking about
when he's looking at his brother here
the thing about Josh Brolin I do love
how they kind of make fun of Robert
Redford like he's like I don't want to
do all this green-screen bullcrap like
I'm a classically trained actor I'm used
to making more traditional movies but
with a lot of these big superhero comic
book movies you just have to shoot a lot
of green screen and then you get to
Thanos which is a hundred percent motion
capture performance it can be really
disorienting like it's a whole other
skill as an actor to have which is why
people have been so upset that Andy
Serkis hasn't won any Oscars for his
motion capture performance like during
the Planet of the Apes films like you
don't really think about it because
you're not looking at his face you're
looking at the characters face but
getting to the Thor battle so they say
Thor and Thanos have the most screen
time
Thanos because it's really his movie
with the other Avengers and it is his
heist movie he's the one that's pulling
off the heist the Thor stuff sort of
tees up a lot of that at the beginning
of the film I think we don't know
exactly when this moment is happening on
the as guardianship but it's probably
really early in the film where it almost
looks like Loki is getting ready to die
so you think about how that my catalyzed
Thor's character infinity war Thor seems
more like a hardcore determined Thor so
the thing that catalyzes him is probably
the death of Loki maybe Heimdall - we
don't know about
Heimdall Loki just seems like he's at
the end of his Road like they did that
whole scene during thor ragnarok build a
statue phony big stitch with my helmet
on with a big dent Aeons I would say
father what you did I didn't do it for
him
[Music]
[Applause]
he's cheated death so many times and
faked us out during phase one and phase
two that it just feels like they're not
gonna do a whole lot with that character
so if we do see Loki after infinity war
and Avengers four it'll be like a
flashback scene like during Ragnarok he
tells the story of how Loki turned him
into a frog and Loki's kind of chuckling
to himself like yeah that was kind of
funny they might have moments like that
in future films where they referenced
Loki and maybe Tom Hiddleston appears as
a vision of some sort but remember how
Odin was still able to communicate with
Thor on a certain level they haven't
really gotten into the idea of Valhalla
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
what happens after they really die but
in addition to Thor wanting to go
rampage against Thanos you also have to
remember that he's the connective tissue
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe right
now Peter quill hasn't been back to
earth since he was a little kid we
haven't met Captain Marvel yet so Thor
is just like the one character who has a
foot in both worlds he like literally
has a foot on the world because he's
been on all these other Avengers phase
one phase two films and he has a foot in
the cosmic realm where the guardians of
the galaxy are because he's traveled all
over the universe growing up beyond that
we get into speculation but in a
separate interview the Russos also
confirm that the people that weren't
featured in a really big way during
infinity war will come to the forefront
in Avengers 4 so don't worry Hawkeye
ant-man and the wasp Captain Marvel
everybody gets a chance bye Avengers
four so let me know in the comments
though what do you take to me and from
there Captain Marvel statement do you
feel like that confirms Captain Marvel
post-credits scene but what will happen
is is they'll be all kinds of Marvel
posting next week don't worry there's
also a Deadpool TV series they haven't
dropped a trailer for yet but I'll
remind people when I post Deadpool movie
videos so they'll also be dropping a
Deadpool trailer in the next couple of
weeks so lots of Deadpool stuff coming
up - congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last video David Moreno
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post a new Marvel click
here for my Hawkeye cut of the infinity
war trailer and click here for the
actual trailer breakdown thank you so
much for watching everybody say awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]